大家好!歡迎來到霍爾代頻道
今天帶來的是股市基礎第二篇
舞蹈量價怎麼看內外盤是什麼?
有時候常常聽到朋友會討論
哪一支股票最近漲很多趕緊去買
結果才沒開心幾天
就聽到他在抱怨當時做的決定
那到底判斷股票市場的買賣依據是什麼?
本次內容將會承接上期影片
講述如何在股票市場上看出供給跟需求的關係
判斷買氣賣氣的方式
如果你是還沒看過第一集的朋友
可以先點擊右上角觀看
那麼
話不多說
我們依舊請到這位自身交易者
來跟大家分享今天的內容
在進入今天的課程前
想問大家還記得
上期影片中
請在下方留言
大家還記得上次影片中演唱會門票的故事嗎?
林小胖在上次買賣演唱會的門票當中
也意識到供給跟需求的重要性
於是他想找一個新的標的物
去嘗試低買高賣的操作
藉此賺到中間的價值
某天林小胖來到了果菜市場
他發現在市場裡有許多叫賣高麗菜的人
也有許多想要購買高麗菜的人
那麼在這個市場上有一個機制
為了讓大家都能用最公平
最適合自己的價格購買到想要的高麗菜
所以賣方跟買方
都可以將自己希望販售與購買的價格
記錄給車和買賣雙方的平台
在圖中我們可以看到
左邊的部分是想要買進的買家
右邊的部分則是想要賣出的賣家
大家依照自己想要的價格排隊掛價
如果今天林小胖想要以現價直接買入高麗菜
就是以右邊上方的第一排價格為成交價
那如果他今天想要以較低的價格買入高麗菜
林小胖就可以用掛買的方式將訂單掛到他想買的價格
等到高麗菜的現價
碟子他所掛買的價格就會自動成交
現在我們以實際操作舉例
林小胖先以現價買進10顆高麗菜
由於50元價格的高麗菜只有5顆
所以剩餘的5顆高麗菜就只能用51元去購買
那麼高麗菜的現價因為林小胖一次購買了10顆高麗菜
所以價格直接提升至了51元
林小胖因為持有高麗菜的平均成本價格為50元到51元之間
所以他決定將他的高麗菜一併掛賣在52元
藉此賺取加差
這個就是無黨量價買賣的過程
現在由於果菜市場想要知道
今天高麗菜究竟是買的人多還是賣的人多
就利用表格將近日的買賣量統計了下來
在圖中,我們可以看到左邊為為買成交的統計
我們稱之為內盤,右邊為為賣成交的統計
我們稱之為外盤
這邊稍微解釋一下
因為以往我在教學時常常有人搞不清楚
內盤等於為賣成交
委託想要買入的人他成交了
那意思就是說有人賣出才有辦法成交
外盤等於為賣成交
委託想要賣出的人他成交了
那意思就是說
有人買入才有辦法成交
以零小胖買入時刻高麗菜的例子可以發現
買入的成交量越多
價格就會向上攀升
反之
只能賣出成交的量越多
價格就會向下跌
這個
就是股市從的內外盤表現
了解這個
就可以一眼看出
股票當天從開盤之後的買期量
與賣期量
我們將內外盤結合供給跟需求可以知道
內盤多
賣出的成交量就多
所以供給大於需求
股價會跌
外盤多
買入的成交量多
所以需求大於供給
股價就會漲
以上指的
都是在一般情況下
但也有例外的時候
至於這個部分
等下期章節
我們再來詳細解說
怎麼樣利用內外盤
找出股價相對應的支撐與壓力
上述是有關於無擋量價與內外盤的使用方式
有些朋友在我還沒上傳前看過了我的影片晚安
問我為什麼不先從KBUN來解釋呢?
對我來說
大家在交易市場上看到的KBUN
也只是價格漲跌的表現
與其去一趟開始
就講述一個由價格衍生出來的記錄方式
那不如講最根本的東西
來讓大家更清楚了解
交易市場的運作方式
大到之間始終是不會錯的
這一系列影片
主要是用淺顯易白的方式
去讓完完全全的新手了解原理
懂了原理
才能夠把基礎打好
衍生出後續的交易策略
在下期影片中
我們將會教大家
如何利用內外盤
去找出股價的支撐與壓力原理
那麼,喜歡我們的影片請幫我們按讚訂閱加分享
有什麼問題也可以在影片下方留言
我將會一則一則回覆你們
最後,請記得開啟小鈴鐺
才不會錯過每一次的更新內容喔!
感謝你的觀看,我們下期影片見!